nous avons franchi un pas passé au
premier passage à gien on nous venons
voulait voir avec ces images aux 60 ans
60 ans que le paris nice n'avait pas
accueilli un départ et une arrivée à
gien depuis le peloton y est passé comme
ici en 1992 mais cette année il
s'arrêtera toute une journée le 9 mars
prochain le temps d'un contre-la-montre
la meilleure étape selon le maire de la
ville en termes de retombées et et je
pense aux retombées d'image et retombées
touristiques
c'est très intéressant puisque les télés
du monde entier vont diffuser cette
cette course nous aurons la chance
d'être en direct pendant deux heures sur
france télévisions et sur eurosport
nous aurons également la ville qui sera
survolée par un hélicoptère pendant deux
heures et je pense que c'est une très
très belle vitrine certes ce n'est pas
le tour de france mais julien espère
bien tirer son épingle du jeu car il
faudra loger et nourrir les 23 équipes
engagées et l'organisation de la course
l'inconnue c'est bien l'épidémie de kovy
de 19 l'an dernier l'arrivée à châlette
sur loing s'était fait sans spectateurs
le club cycliste local croise les doigts
mais on espère que
le virus qui nous gêne tant sort aura
disparu ou presque pour nous laisser
libre
ce jour là et que tout le monde puisse
être sur le circuit sans souci les
coureurs s'élanceront depuis le quai de
nice pour une boucle de 14 km 400 à
l'extérieur du centre ville ils
passeront notamment devant la faïencerie
de gien qui fête cette année ses 200 ans
arrivée prévue place du château pour
être une ville étape sur ce paris nice
vient aura déboursé 30 mille euros